Vegas golden fans are loyal and they
often attribute the team to unifying the
community following one October of
course there is an online community
giving women a voice in hockey Lauren
negretti is live at City National Lorena
with the story Lauren good morning to
you
good morning yes that loyal and just all
about just team spirit fan base really
goes beyond gender norms and that online
community they're called vgk ladies
proves just that it's formed on Facebook
back in 2017 and the women say it gives
them a sense of community and something
to celebrate given the team formed
shortly before what October and became a
force and a reason to Rally behind
I'm a table games dealer down on the
Strip was there during October 1st and
that team meant everything to us because
it was the only reason we could cheer
let's go go Knights go
go Knights go and cheer they do the
women say they formed lifelong friends
and the group gives them a space a safe
space to be fans without any judgment
again puck drop tonight at 5 p.m here we
are gonna they are having a watch party
over there at Flamingo Parkway Tavern
near Flamingo and the 215. they're doing
prizes and a shot with every goal now I
reached out to Parkway Tavern who let me
know that they are having a electronic
billboard out in the parking lot to
expand their viewing area so a fun time
go nights go over here live outside the
city National Arena Laura negretti 8
news now back to you guys I think Uber
and Lyft are going to be busy tonight
let's hope so Lord thank you very much